What do you like me?
Tight exactly why you want to put in your pocket
The same is true for item sales.
It is most important that you show the item you want
I'll let you know how to do it.
Hello.
Advance item sales Start advertising
If you are a user like you
So you just have to show them the items you want to ride
I gave it to you.
If you do not see it, come see me now.
However, no matter how many users you purchase,
100 If my life shows the same item to the Son of Man
Well, that's not it.
The more you can advertise the items that fit the user-by-user decomposition, the more
So you can make a profit, so AdMob can
I prepared.
If you use this, you can customize it for 9 minutes
9 minutes Use it to sell the right item or promote another inside
Even those users only
You can also provide instructions
So let's take a peek at how the prospects feed.
Let Ed Mobs use the House Advertising feature and Ed Thoggogle Analytics together
It's possible
We use Analytics to collect data.
After making it an audience list in AdMob
When creating an Adam item sales ad,
I am interested in selling only those users who belong to Montgomery.
You'll be able to see your ad.
First, let's set it up first.
Please connect me.
If you do not have one, you can make it right away.
Oh, you can not do it again.
Are you ready then you will see this screen
At the bottom left, select Create an audience and click the new locked customer button.
Press
If you click New here, you'll see that Analytics automatically
You can create a user list from the settings of the conditions
In addition to these, conditions such as the nap user level
To create a list, use Analytics, and pre-create an event.
please
So the event came up in the area of ​​advanced Iran below.
If you do not know anything about the event,
Please refer to
You do not have to create a new audience list.
Go back and press the Segment button once.
You can use the segment you created right away.
You can use the recommended segment to make it look more comfortable.
Let's create a new user list.
Name it New User Test.
You just saved it.
Now you can set this item to show you what item to sell.
Let's go ahead and advertise the item sales that we made in the previous video.
Please select
And when you open the settings, you'll see advanced ad targeting.
Click here to see if you have a list of new user tests you have created
Find
If you do not see it, do not get hurt.
Please try
Then you will see again. Select 2 to add and save.
It's finished.
Now, for those users who are likely to pay for the item sales ads,
It's only visible to users.
Now all the settings are done.
I just need to adapt the code.
Let's see.
I need your help.
It is in favor of both. In order to have more time, we need two things.
How to properly mark the items you want with proper targeting
It's a way to measure the performance of your ads.
So from now on, how do you analyze and target your behavior in your app?
Let's see if we can measure the performance of an item sales ad.
In order to record and analyze the behavior of Mnet users,
You can use it through Google Play services
There is
Many developers, including me, say that data analysis is somewhat complex
You feel like you have a hard time.
In fact, if you look at the complex menu and the unfamiliar terms,
Do it
One good news is that Google has just released a few basic features
The fact is that you can effectively target users
Let's take a look at what features we can leverage.
In order to use any of these special functions,
You must create a tracker to record
If you link your account to Google via your account,
You can get a tracking id.
You can create tracker objects using these tracking children.
First, demographic information like user age gender
Which can be used in common across all apps, such as
To enable you to verify the information, enable basic tracking as follows:
It's just a couple of lines, but when you open it,
And it allows you to target users based on activities they have visited.
Have been
Furthermore, it's important for your apps, such as your stage clearance government
You can also use event information to target your ads.
4 led an ordinance player and level pack 1 say my player the same
If you advertise an item,
Take advantage of the event builder included in tc to get it to your desired value
Event Category Action
You can set up information such as labels to be forwarded to the server and saved
Just call the sandbox function on the cracker.
The data will soon accumulate in the tick sub and will be based on this information
Create an audience list and target users to show the most relevant ads.
can
So how do you measure the performance of these item sales ads?
Download the Google Conversion Tracking SDK and download the included resource files
You need to add it to your project
If you are using your Play Store für Switzerland,
Add conversion track quest k to your project and you're ready.
Each time an item is sold, the result is automatically sent to the server in the callback
You can check the effect of the ad at a glance on the tab to make it publicize on Ed Page
can
It seems that there is an item sale.
If you are using a pulse listener for some reason, you should add a little
I do.
Each time a user clicks on an item sale, on first request callback
You can call this code play billing resolution method directly in
You must be a server.
Likewise, ad performance can be checked through the tabs to make the ad richer
Until now, I do not know how to write user behavior based on potential customers
A basic way to create a list and target users is to use the
I looked at how to measure performance.
Effective ways to target your ads are based on the nature and user
It could vary from floor to floor.
For more information, see the developer site documentation and the Google Korea Developer Blog
Please note
Always do not lie data Joe Ad Mocha Google One Piece powerful
You can take advantage of the features to test different methods and
Now that you've provided a user experience, let's make more money.
Thank you
e25
sweat